birthday party day
the Kardashians have done it again Kim
and Kourtney just through daughters
Northwest and Penelope Disick a
Candyland themed birthday party and like
always it was epic oh my god the reality
stars took to their I G stories to give
us an inside look at the Saturday soiree
which featured a giant board game path
across the backyard
bounce house and all the sugar you can
imagine mr. softy is here and let's not
forget about North and Penelope's candy
filled rainbow cake needless to say
there were a lot of sugar highs that day
of course auntie Chloe was at the event
so was grandma Kris Jenner do you think
these are the legs of a 20 year olds
now this isn't the first time the
cousins have celebrated their birthdays
together last year the girls had a
unicorn themed bash
in 2017 it was Moana and in 2016 the
theme was mermaid and in typical
Kardashian fashion Kim took to Instagram
to wish her sweet daughter a happy sixth
birthday riding the last six years have
been the best of my life raising you and
seeing you grow up mommy loves you
forever and beyond Penelope will turn
seven on July 8th
[Music]